Now, that this is documentation
or his version of events if you
will. What I mean by that is
that when you have an something
that occurred, an occurrence,
an incident as major as the
night journey. This a lot and
as major as the Ascension, of
the prophet
to the heavens. This is
regarded amongst the scholars
as being the greatest event of
any human being. And so the
accounts of this event are
carried by innumerable
narrators. So, we can expect
that there will be some fine
diff fine details with regards
to what came first, what came
second because of the sheer
amount of testimony regarding
this event. Because of that,
there are some minor details
and again, these details are
regarding
are regarding the issue of
order, the order of events
details with regards to the
order of events cause a little
bit of a stir amongst the
narrators. So, we can expect
that if this happened in the
year ten after Hijalah or if
this happened in the year 11
after Hijalah or twelve
difference of opinion. That the
prophet spent at least ten
almost 15 years and this would
come up at different times. He
would relate different aspects
of it at different times. When
it first happened, he would
have related it to the
companions. That were Muslim at
the time. After Hijra, he might
relate certain parts of it in
certain in under certain
circumstances, right? So, let's
say for instance, the prophet
is speaking about the dangers
of backbiting. For instance,
and then Something He was shown
something that is related to
that on the night of so he may
say to the companions that
happened to be there and on the
night of Al Mirage, I saw such
and such. Right? That has to do
with this issue that's that
they're dealing with at the
moment. So, that's a fragment.
It's a fragment of what
happened. This is something a
lot of people don't understand
about the issue of about
narrations. Narrations, they
can happen all at once or they
can happen in fragments because
if a companion is sitting in a
gathering and the issue of
Rebbe comes up, right? Well,
not all night journey has to do
with Riba. A small portion of
it. Something happens,
something that was seen,
something that he told. So,
he'll mention just what is
pertinent to the situation or
the gathering or the speech
that he's giving at the moment.
So, if we go through now, all
of the narrations throughout
recorded Islamic history, of
everyone who is recorded to
have discussed any part of the
Isra and Maharaj and we put all
of that together we try to make
a complete picture, a complete
narrative from beginning to
end, right? And because not all
narrations are the same, some
of them have stronger chains of
narration, some of them have
weaker chains of narration,
some of them have no chain of
narration, right? So, we have
to expect that there will be
small details that narrators do
not necessarily agree on but
the issue itself is All agreed
upon. This is something that is
referred to in the science of
Hadith as this is meaning that
this is something that is known
of the prophet
biography to everyone. It's
what's referred to as common
knowledge. We have an almost
enumerable amount of narrators
for this incident. Hundreds.
Right? perhaps dozens if not
more companions who narrate
some some aspect of it and we
have hundreds and then on to
into thousands of narrators who
brought the narrations to us.
Because of this, there are a
few details which are disagreed
upon. Amongst the this is
historians and the scholars of
Hadith. One of those details is
was this What year did Al Islat
when Maharaj take place, right?
That's a deal that they differ
on. Some scholars mention the
12th year, some mention 11th
year after his prophethood. So,
mention the tenth. So, mention
the second, right? But we know
that it happened before
Hijalah. Another issue that is
debated amongst the scholars is
who were the prophets that he
led in salah? Right? We know
that he led the prophets in
salah in Al Masjid al Aqsa. Was
it every single prophet ever?
Right? Or was it just a a group
of prophets? Or was it only
those prophets that he saw in
the heavens that he
encountered? Was this before
the Ascension? After the
ascension. Right? Another issue
is who did he see in which
heaven? Cuz it's seven seven
heavens. And each heaven's gate
that he entered. He was
presented and acquainted with a
prophet. Right? Who were those
prophets? Slight variation in
the narrations with regards to
that. This is not the prophet
narrating a different This is
the people that heard it from
him and perhaps got the order
one or two of them and others
got it correct. So, the
scholars of Hadith now have to
gather all those narrations and
look what is the chain of
narration and the most credible
account, right? In order to
iron out those details. It's a
very tedious task but it's
something that has been done
obviously and so, Ibn Rahima
Allah, he's going to tell us
now the correct opinion with
regards to these events. Avi
I'm mentioning what Ibn
mentions which he doesn't go
into extreme detail. he just
mentions over the course of a
few pages. A very comprehensive
account of is the account
documented by Ibn Kathir,
Rahima Allah. If you want to
read basically every credible
narration ever narrated about
you would read the original the
first the first his on the
first verse of
the he has a huge essay that he
compiled all those narrations
together and you can see
basically every credible
narration with regards to that
issue so here we're going to
kind of merge them together
right and tried to give a
coherent, most likely account
of what occurred on the night
of and the night of Al Miraj.
Ibn Al he says,
[Silence]
journey? Or was it literally
his body he was taken on this
journey? And the majority, the
vast majority of the scholars
to the point that it's almost
an issue of consensus. hold
the opinion and affirm that it
was with his body and soul
both. He literally, physically
went on this night journey and
that's what makes it so
miraculous, right? This night
journey was from Al Masjid al
Haram to
it doesn't mean that he was
inside the Masjid, the Kaaba,
right? Actually, in the
narration of Abudar in a Sahir,
he was actually in his aunt's
house when this occur
and the prophet mentions that
he was sleeping and the roof or
the top of the house was
removed. And Jibrael Alaihi
Salam descended to him and
began the preparations for the
night journey. One of the
things that happened was that
the prophet
tells us in Muslim that his
heart was extracted by Jibreel.
Right? This is a physical thing
that happened. His chest was
opened. And in one narration,
the prophet
relates that his chest was open
from Al or to his navel. And
then another wording to his
pubic region. This was all
opened. And his heart was taken
out. Jibreel Alaihi Salam
brought with other angels a
basin made of gold and water
from Zemzem and the prophet
heart was placed into this
blessed bath. And a a It say a
clot of black was taken out of
his heart. And Jibreel showed
it to the prophet and said
this is this amount, this thing
here, this is all a Shaitan has
of you. Meaning of your heart.
And then he discarded it.
Right? Now, again, how is a man
not having his heart and his
body having a conversation?
This is beyond the realm of our
[Arabic recitation]
right? And so, he took this
clot out and washed the
prophet's heart in this basin
of gold with the water of
Zemzem, and then he stuffed his
heart with wisdom and faith
right? So,
[Arabic recitation]
then he replaced it in the
prophet chest. And sealed the
wound. Now, this is a physical
thing. NS, and a was one of the
prophet personal servants. So,
we have a lot of narrations of
things that the prophet did in
his house. or certain
aspects of his body related to
us by Enes because Ennis was a
young boy and he would always
be tending to the prophet in
his house, in in Madina. And he
saw the prophet with a shirt
on, without a shirt. He saw his
body. He knows is the one who
relates to us. Even the amount
of white hairs that were in the
prophet head, right? So, he's
one of the very intimate
companions of the prophet and
us narrates to us that he
always sought the stitching on
the prophet chest from that
incident, right? So, this is a
physical thing that happened.
This happened twice in his
lifetime. It happened once as a
young boy when he was living
with his
his mother of suckling, Halima,
a Sadiya, is a young boy. He
was playing with the other
children and a great light like
that of a lightning strike
happened and his heart was
extracted and purified at that
time. This was before he was a
prophet. Sallallahu And this is
actually what caused and this
was the catalyst for him
returning to Mecca. Because
when she saw this happen, well,
she didn't see it. She actually
heard. The other kids came and
told her, this is what we saw
happen. She became very, very
scared that something would
happen to him and her care. So,
she urged that he be returned
to his to his family in Mecca
after this incident. This is
the second time that this
occurred. Now, why did it occur
twice? Significance of it
occurring before or before his
prophethood and after.
Obviously, there are many
wisdoms in that but person's
heart as a child and a person's
heart as an adult, and so this
occurring and especially before
he was taken to meet Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is that his
heart was purified physically
and spiritually and additional
time because he was going to
meet Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
So, he was being prepared for
prophethood in the first one
and he was being for Allah's
meeting in the second one,
right? And this kind of
articulates to us what it is we
need to do in preparing
ourselves to meet Allah. Right?
Think about it. The prophet is
going to meet Allah and his
heart is extracted and purified
and washed physically and
spiritually. This tells us that
When Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says
whoever desires the meaning of
his lord meaning that when we
meet Allah, we need to work in
our lives to try to purify
ourselves in the same way.
Obviously, not by removing our
hearts but by removing the
filth that is contained in our
hearts and by trying fill our
hearts and flood our hearts
with the words of Allah and
Revelation and light and and
piety and and faith as much as
we possibly can working towards
the meeting of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. And so after this
Jibreel Alayhi Salam brought to
him an animal referred to as Al
Burak. Prophet gave us two main
descriptions of this animal,
this barak. The first
description was that Canabena.
The first description of is
that this animal was smaller
than a mule but bigger than a a
donkey. It was in that range,
right?
And the second description that
the prophet gave us of Al Burak
is
That this animal has the
ability to place his hoof, his
foot as far as its eyes see.
Right? He didn't describe it as
having wings. He didn't
describe it in a lot of these
other things that we see and
honestly, it's unfortunate and
we discussed this last week but
it's unfortunate that
sometimes, people have tried to
create art, right? Draw
pictures of Al Boraq and
they've even taken, you know,
some books you can buy My even
have these pictures on the
cover which is obviously
something that is
unacceptable because it
cheapens the book and it
cheapens you know, this is not
a book of fairy tales and this
is real life. This is what the
prophet did. So, you'll see on
the cover of a book about Al Is
or the cover of a book about
the prophets
biography and you'll see a
horse, you know, a white
horse with with wings like
dove wings. This has nothing to
do with the actual description
of Al Baraq. Al Baraq, the the
name Boraq Alawazni, Fual,
Mahudun Mil Bark, this word is
derivative of the word al Bach
which is lightning, right? So,
it is described with this
description, etymologically,
that it is swift and fast
you know, similar to Albarch.
And so, these are the
descriptions of Al Baraq, the
prophet then got onto Albarak.
And he began his night journey
to now on his night journey
between Al Masjid Al Haram to
Al Masjid al Aqsa he saw a
number of things. Right? And
one of the things that he saw
was on his way a Shaitan tried
to deter him from this journey.
He tried to lead him off of the
path from Me to Medina and to
get him lost in the vast desert
between the two Mashajid.
However, he was he remained
steadfast and he was not
deterred by a Shaitan and he
was not sidetracked by a
Shaitan, shimmering, and trying
to trying to attract him off of
the path He reached there in Al
Masjid Al Aqsa. And
Masjid. And he tied Al Burak
there. Some accounts mentioned
that it was in the the ring on
the actual door. Right? Other
accounts mentioned that. It was
a place that Jibreel Alaihi
Salam had carved out of a
stone. But in some narrations
the prophet said that this is a
place where all of the prophets
tie their animal, right? And so
he tied al Barak there.
Mentions that he prayed and led
the other prophets in salah.
This is very significant. Now,
which prophets were they? Some
scholars mention all of the
prophets, some of them mention
a group of prophets but we know
that the cardinal or chief
prophets and messengers,
Ibrahim and Musa and Isa and
Noor and
and these messengers were there
were present and he led them in
salah. This articulates what it
articulates that. The prophet
Muhammad legislation is the
final legislation and it
abrogates those previous
religions or legislations of
the prophets before. And that
if any of those prophets were
alive today and amongst us
today, they would find guidance
only by ad hering to the
prophet message.
Right? And so, What this means
is that a person may say, you
know, yeah, I believe in I
believe in the prophet
Muhammad. I believe that he was
a prophet but I also believe in
Musa and I want I follow Musa
Alaihi Salam, right? As some of
the Rabbis and Jews of Medina
had done in the prophet's time
or a person who was Christian
will say, yes, I believe he was
a prophet. However I'm
following Risa Alaihi Salam. I
believe he's a prophet but I
follow this prophet over here.
We say that this is invalid
because those prophets if they
were alive today, they would
have no choice but to follow
the prophet Muhammad
Jabber, Hadith, Omar, Fisunan,
Al Musnad, Musnad Ahmed, and
then Nabi
[Silence]
me, you would be misled. You
would be misguided. And so, he
led the prophets in prayer.
Some of the scholars mentioned
that this happened after he
returned from the heavens.
Others mentioned that it was
before he ascended. And their
case. Tells us that what is
definitely not correct is that
instead of arriving at he
instead arrived at Bethlehem,
Bethlehem. This is found in
some vague narrations and this
is inauthentic. It is not
correct that he went to
Bethlehem or Bethlehem
Bethlehem in his night journey.
Rather he went from Al Masjid
Al Haram to Al Masjid al Aqsa.
First
Adam
[Silence]
That there was a which means
that there were stairs, steps
that he took. In either case,
he ascended into the heavens
and when they arrived at the
first heaven, at its gates,
Jibreel requested a gate to be
opened and so the gate was
opened for Jibreel and Muhammad
and when they entered into the
first heaven, they found there
Adam Alaihi Salam.
Conveyed a salaam to him and he
responded to a salaam and he
welcomed him warmly and he
testified to the prophet
Muhammad prophethood and
believed in him And Adam Alaihi
Salam had there to his right
the souls of all of his
offspring. All of humanity. We
were there. All of us. Right?
The souls of all of his
offspring to his right as being
the people of paradise and to
his left the souls of the
damned. And so this is one of
the cases or one of the
instances where the people of
the right are taken from.
Right? There are the people of
the right, and the people of
the left.
The of the right. They are
those who were to the right of
Adam Alaihi Salam that night.
And the people of the left were
the damned, the forsaken, they
were the people of the left. To
the left of Adam, Alaihi Salam.
There are other reasons of
course. And this is one of the
reasons that we are encouraged
to treat the the right
different than the left. Had a
[Silence]
He would begin with the right
side, the right foot, combing
the hair beginning with the
right side, right? And when he
would bathe and make Udu, he
would begin with the right And
he would do this consistently
in anything where he would have
to choose between doing the
right or the left first. He
would give precedence to the
right. This is why. This is in
preparation and memorium two
being of the people of the
right.
And so he was then taken to the
gates of the second heaven
Again, the same process
happened. Jibreel Alaihi Salam
requested the gate to be
opened. The gatekeepers of the
second heaven from amongst the
angels opened and there in the
second heaven, he was
acquainted with Yahia and Asah.
Yahia and Aisa, why these two
together? Asa Alaihi Salam was
taken up to the heaven, right?
Taken up to the heavens and he
still remains alive therein in
the heavens. In the second
heaven, as we have here, and so
when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says,
where Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions and relates to us that
he said to
I am going to conclude your
time on the earth now for now
and take you up into the
heavens that he was taken into
the second heaven
Allah raised. To himself.
Meaning into the heavens. And
he remains there in the second
heaven. Passed away on the
earth. And as did Adam and as
did all of the rest of the
prophets that were going to
hear about. Is the only one
from amongst all of those
prophets. That had not yet met
his time of death. Right? I
want to mention
and kind of bring something to
our attention. When we read
many of the narrations
we notice two things. The first
is that they mention almost
always together which means
that they happened at the same
time. They happened together,
right? And it is incorrect that
Al Isra happened on a separate
night from they happened on the
same night. Second thing we
notice in these narrations of
didn't mention it here but it
was mentioned particularly by
the prophet in a number of
times. And that is that every
time Jibreel Alaihi Salam would
arrive at one of the heavens,
the first or the second or the
third and he would request that
the gatekeepers of the angels
of that heaven open that heaven
for them to enter
[Silence]
Fayakul, Jibreel, or Mohammed.
Opened the gatekeeper says, who
is this? And Jibreel responds,
Jibreel and Mohammed. And the
gatekeeper then says, has he
already been sent? Meaning that
they were unaware that he had
already been sent as a
messenger. Why is that? How is
it that he was on the Earth for
10 years, 11 years years 12
years as a prophet, as a
messenger. The Quran is coming
to is bringing it to the
prophet Muhammad etcetera
etcetera. And these gatekeepers
of the heavens seem to be
unaware that he has already
been sent. It's incorrect for
us to look at time on this
earth. The same as it is
perceived in the heavens. All
of this could be a matter of
moments. With regards to the
angels in the heavens. I mean,
if you think about it, was
taken up into the second
heaven. How long ago, like
almost 2000 years ago, right?
So, 2000 years ago, he was
taken up into the heavens and
so he's been up there for 2000
years, right? That's a long
life. Does that mean that Isa
Alaihi Salam has a longer life
than any of the other prophets
and messengers? I mean, Adam
Alaihi Salam's life was how
long? A thousand years, right?
And he gave 40 of those
thousand years to Dawood Alaihi
Salam. And that answer to that
is that Isa Alaihi Salam in the
heaven, the second heaven does
he perceive time to be 2000
years of lapsed as we perceive
it here on the Earth? Very,
very unlikely that that is the
case. Or Isa Alai Islam, it
could seem a couple of
days, just a few days. Right?
Time is very, very different.
Outside of Earth. Actually,
time is very different. The
further you get from Earth and
the faster something goes. An
object goes and you know, there
have been experiments done.
With atomic clocks and sending
them into space and speeding
them up and so forth. That's
they would keep a clock here on
Earth Send a clock into space.
Get it further from gravity.
Speed it up faster than the
other clock and bring them back
together and one would have
gone slightly faster than the
other, right? What does this
mean? This means that time on
Earth here is relative. It's
kind of light, right? It's
relative and so,
time as perceived by the
gatekeepers of the heavens, the
angels as perceived by and so
forth. As perceived by people
in their graves. Right? Is not
the same as we perceive and
experience time here on Earth.
Even different animals.
Experience time on earth
differently than others.
depending on their makeup. And
so the point here is that when
we read these narrations, we
see that there is a difference
in the way that time is
experienced by these angels and
by these prophets. So, there he
met Asah and Yahia. The prophet
commented and said, Ibn ,
they are cousins, maternal
cousins, Yahia and and Isa
Alaihi Salam. And then he was
taken to the third heaven. And
the same process repeats
itself. There in the third
heaven, he was acquainted with
Yusuf Alaihi Salam. Then the
fourth heaven, where he was,
acquainted with Idris.
Idris Alaihi Salam in the
correct opinion of historians
is one of the prophets of Beni
Israel.
Box history books, books on the
stories of the prophets. Often
mention Idris as preceding
around
I